I mean it's the worst fake crying while
we're seeing she's just using the
technique but what the technique holy
Amanda this is my stepdad mark how long
are you here oh man
my mom's gonna pick me up around
midnight midnight slate for us I'll call
your mom she can come pick you up now
she's busy doing more chemotherapy I
[Music]
don't have any feelings ever and that
doesn't necessarily make me a bad person
just means I have to work a little
harder to be good I'm sending you to
boarding school after that you're off my
payroll
you ain't him you despise him
hi maybe I think you can't go in looking
like that I'm fine just not gonna have
to stand here all day like a robot
repeating myself I'm fine I'm fine I'm
fine I'm fine everything by just killing
him how would you what the hell is he
even doing it I am providing them all
with early drug experiences that you
will forever cherish look that how are
you we have a business proposition for
you you've got a gun
yes I have a gun you don't know or I
come for question sir a man you have no
idea I couldn't think you'd bring it
here hold it no thanks anyway you cannot
hesitate the only thing worse is being
incompetent or being unkind or being
evil is being indecisive okay shall we
[Music]
what am I gonna tell it where I hat
we're keeping this by the way
[Music]
[Music]